in this video you're going to learn how
to solve and graph compound inequalities
we're going to go through four examples
together and we're going to talk about
how to work with these so first of all
what exactly is a compound inequality
well it's two inequalities that are
basically put together with the word and
or or and what and means it means it's
like the intersection or the overlap of
the two solutions of the two
inequalities whereas or represents like
the union meaning it's like a
combination of both of those solution
sets so we're going to see how this
works in these four examples the first
example we have is an or type 3x plus 5
is less than 2 or 2x minus 1 is greater
than or equal to 5. and just a reminder
when you look at these inequality
symbols it's just like when you read a
sentence from left to right when you
look at the symbol it kind of looks like
the letter L for less than the other way
to think about it is it points to the
smaller quantity and it is like an
alligator like going after the larger
quantity so you can see 3x plus 5 is
smaller or less than two and of course
this is going to be greater than
or equal to so this is kind of like half
of an equal sign so when you go ahead
and solve these it's just like solving
an equation you want to get the
variables on one side numbers on the
other side so we're going to subtract 5
from both sides
so now we have 3x is less than negative
3 and we're going to divide both sides
by 3 to get X by itself
so now we have X is less than negative
1.
and then over here we're going to try to
get this variable by itself so first
we're going to add 1 to both sides
so we have two x's greater than or equal
to 6 and then we're going to divide both
sides by 2 and we can see that X is
greater than or equal to 3. now one
thing you want to be careful of when
you're solving inequalities is that if
you multiply or divide by a negative
number what happens is the inequality
sign is going to flip or change
direction so just if you yourself
multiply or divide both sides by a
negative number now notice this is an or
so what we can do is we can go to our
number line
and we can say x is less than negative
1. so what does that mean less than
negative one well it doesn't include
negative one so we're going to draw this
as an open circle like Hollow lesson
means it includes the points here that
are less than or lower smaller than
negative one and as we go to the left
the numbers are getting smaller right
whereas the second inequality let's go
over to 0 1 2 3 x is greater than or
equal to 3 so equal to 3
or greater as we go to the right the
numbers are getting larger and then when
you see that word or that means Union it
means it's all of these values as well
as all these values so it's like the
combination of the total here so it's
basically everything that we have
graphed so this is the solution to the
first example let's take a look at the
next example okay let's look at number
two now we've got negative 12 is less
than 5x plus 3 is less than or equal to
23. so this particular one is different
than the first example the first example
was an or this one is an implied and and
what does that mean well you can see
what we have here is we have actually
two inequalities that are put together
we have this one which let's write it
over here separately negative 12 is less
than 5x Plus 3. and here's our implied
and we have this inequality on the right
side we have 5x plus 3 is less than or
equal to 23. so one way to do this is to
split it apart into two inequalities and
solve them separately so let's go ahead
and do that so what we're going to do is
think about getting the variables on one
side numbers on the other so I'm going
to subtract 3 from both sides
of the inequality
and we want to solve for x I'm going to
divide both sides by 5.
okay and so now we have negative 3 is
less than X or you could say x is
greater than negative 3. I just flip
that inequality over for the second one
we're going to get the numbers on one
side variables on the other so we have
5x is less than or equal to 20. divide
both sides by 5 to get X by itself
so we have X is less than or equal to 4.
and keep in mind that this is an and so
our solution is X is greater than
negative 3 and X is less than or equal
to 4. now graphically what this looks
like
on the number line negative 3 is over
here 0 somewhere over here 4 is
somewhere over here I'm going to go from
low to high so what we have is X is
greater than
negative three so greater than we're
graphing to the right it's getting
larger and at the same time x is less
than or equal to so equal to is a closed
Circle less than means we're going to
the left or smaller but the and means
the overlap or the intersection of the
two sets is what they have in common so
you can see they're overlapping right
here
okay up to that point so our final
result our answer here that we can graph
on the number line is going to be from
negative 3
to 4 including 4
and what we can do with these two
inequalities we can put them back
together as like one inequality and the
way that I would do that is you see how
here how we have X is greater than
negative 3 or negative 3 is less than x
so let's write that down negative 3 is
less than x and at the same time x is
less than or equal to 4.
and so you can see X is in between see
negative 3 and 4. not including negative
3 but including positive four it's like
X is sandwiched in between and you can
still see we have those two inequalities
here we have
X is greater than negative 3 and we have
X is less than or equal to four it's
just so we put them together as like one
inequality the one thing you want to be
careful of when you put these together
you always want these inequality signs
to be pointing
to the left so they could be less than
or less than or equal to you always want
that variable in the middle and you're
going to find that the smaller number
here is on the left and the larger
numbers here on the right and the
variable is like in between that smaller
and greater number now if you have a
situation where they're pointed like
this
you can flip this whole inequality so
that it's in this proper form let's take
a look at another example for number
three we've got 2x minus 7 is less than
4X plus 3 or 1 half X plus four is
greater than or equal to eight so how
would we solve that one
well when it's in or we can just solve
these individually and then remember or
means Union so it's like we're going to
look at the combination of the two
solution sets so when we do this
we want to get the variables on one side
numbers on the other just like solving
equations what I'm going to do is I'm
going to add 7 to both sides
okay so that gives us 2x is less than 4X
plus 10 then I'm going to get the
variables on the other side so I'm going
to subtract 4X from both sides
so that gives us negative 2x is less
than 10 and I'm going to divide both
sides by negative 2 to get X by itself
now remember when you multiply or divide
both sides by a negative the inequality
sign changes Direction so this is going
to be X is greater than negative 5. now
for the other inequality we're going to
get the variables on one side numbers on
the other so we have one half X is
greater than or equal to 4. Let's
multiply both sides by 2 because 1 half
times two is one that will give us the
variable by itself
X is greater than or equal to 8.
okay so we have let's go to the number
line now we've got these two
inequalities we have negative five
so X is greater than negative 5 so that
means to the right of negative 5
0 somewhere over here 8 somewhere over
here or X is greater than
or equal to
8. now or means Union so we're basically
taking all of these numbers like
negative 5 negative 4.5 negative four
all these numbers here
as well as all these numbers here so
we're like combining these together it's
the union union means like you're
uniting the two sets so our final result
is going to be
this right here on our number line and
our answer is just going to be X is
greater than negative 5.
now if this was an and problem and means
the intersection we'd say oh where are
they overlapping they're only
overlapping from 8 or to the right so X
is greater than or equal to 8. but with
or we're talking about the union we
actually combine these together into one
and that that answer here is graphed on
the number line X is greater than
negative 5. let's take a look at another
example
okay before we do this last uh number
four and type of problem if you like the
way that I explain things and you want
to go deeper into Algebra 1 or Algebra 2
with me check out my video courses for
sale I'll put a link in the description
below and I take you through 85 lessons
in the one course 87 lessons in the
other course we go through the concepts
we go through example problems I give
you some problems that you can practice
on your own and we'll go through those
together as well and I take you step by
step building on the previous Concepts
to help you walk through both Algebra 1
or the algebra 2 college algebra course
so check those out if you're studying
that and let's dive into this last
example together so you can see that
this is an and type and in the first
example we broke them apart into two
separate inequalities and then at the
very end we put them back together
remember that
but there's another way to do this and
that's to get the variable by itself in
the middle and it's like solving the two
inequalities at the same time like
simultaneously so what I mean by that is
we're trying to get this x by itself so
instead of subtracting 2 let's add 2 to
the left
to the right and to the middle and so if
we do that you can see we're getting
negative 6 is less than negative 1 3 x
is less than or equal to negative 3. now
here we want to get our X our variable
by itself in the middle so the negative
1 3 times x we could divide by negative
1 3 or multiply everything by negative
3. so let's go ahead and multiply by the
reciprocal negative three that's going
to give us 18 here that's going to give
us 9 here that's going to give us X here
but remember when you multiply or divide
both sides of an inequality by a
negative number that inequality sign is
going to change direction so that's
going to make this a greater than or
equal to that's going to make this a
greater than
but remember that little caveat we
talked about earlier you really want
these inequality signs to be pointing to
the left you want to be less than or
less than or equal to science so what I
have to do is pick up this whole
inequality and flip it okay so that's
what I'm going to do I'm going to take
it flip it over this is going to become
9 is here 18 is here when I flip it this
is going to be a less than or equal to
and this is going to be a less than
now it's going to be a little bit easier
to graph we can go on our number line
we can say here's 9 here's 18 and X is
sandwiched in between 9 and 18. it's
actually greater than or equal to 9. see
greater than or equal to 9 and at the
same time it's less than or smaller than
18. so it's in between
9 and 18. it includes 9 but it doesn't
include 18. so this is
you know your solution this is like a
graph of our solution and remember this
includes not just integer values but
fractions and decimals and basically
everything in between these two points
so great job if you're able to follow
this video if you want more practice
I'll put another video right there
follow me over that video and we'll get
some more practice I'll see you there